We've got our new variable your joined so let's look
at its summary it looks like most of our users
joined in 2012 or 2013 and since the values for
this variable are discreet and the range is pretty narrow I'm
going to go ahead and table this variable as well.
Here we can see the distributions of users and each year
joined. Notice that there isn't much data here about early
joiners. To increase the data we have in each tenure category,
we can group some of these years together. The
cut function is often quite useful for making discrete variables
from continuous or numerical ones, sometimes in combination with the
function quantile. Now what I want you to do is
to look at the documentation for cut, and refer
to the link in the instructor notes to complete this
next programming exercise. Your task is to cut the variable
year joined to create four bins, or buckets of users.
The bins will be from 2004 to 2009, 2009
to 2011, 2011 to 2012, and then 2012 to 2014.